I was wondering what is the most extreme
aftermath you've experienced after a big
night out I mean pretty extreme ones
[Music]
walkabouts kammo with me Josh Smith and
today we are joined by the living legend
and the queen of period dramas is Keira
Knightley hello thanks I've never been
called a living legend before that's
exciting thank you know what I really
loved about this film is the exploration
of mental health and how if you don't
discuss it
it gets worse the problems worsen why do
you think it's so important as a role
model yourself to come out and speak
about these kind of problems I think
it's very important that that
particularly young people but actually
everybody knows that everyone breaks
that it's sort of a part of life that
what you have to do at that point is
acknowledge it and ask for help if
you're lucky enough to be able to get
that helpful but there is no shame in in
admitting that you can't cope at a
certain point and particularly with me
in my career you know you want to try
and be helpful and say yeah I know this
is all terribly glamorous and hey look
at this dress and all the rest of it but
you know behind that of course there's a
human being and of course there are
moments where I haven't been able to
cope and I've been really lucky that I
could afford the help that I needed when
when I got it and really lucky that I
had a family there that were very very
supportive but ultimately it's nothing
to feel ashamed about and I think
particularly with men you know there's a
big kind of feeling that you shouldn't
have these emotions and you should be
able to cope and you should be able to
man up and yeah definitely that's part
of this this film particularly in that
generation that silent generation that
just didn't talk about him and I think
men do have to acknowledge their
emotions as they do you have to talk
about it and it's okay to cry cuz you're
a human being like how I cried in this
film like hey I like her cries you play
such a strong female role in this and I
think so many people will come in here
and ask you about that line about what's
it like to play strong wife role but
then no one's ever really gonna go in
and ask the guy who plays the husband
what's it like to play a powerful
husband role when you come into
interviews in 2019 do you still
experience like sexist questions like
that yeah of course
I mean of course yeah yeah I mean it's
the end it's the same one you know you
ask a woman how does she balance being a
mother how do you I play this role
because I'm a mother I'm sure
he's gone into you know Jason and girl
oh did you play this role because you're
a father you know I mean it and how do
you balance your work with being a
father you know it's still not something
that we asked men and yet it's
constantly something there we're on
completely different playing fields
still in 2019 we don't even get paid as
much as you guys for doing exactly the
same job well you know so I think we've
still got a way to go in in multiple
different directions and we need more
male allies definitely always sure
always very very ways get involved
exactly I was gonna say man up but
actually just just just be yourselves it
does get a bit racy yeah this felt it's
like a pair of John move aside of like
raunchy sauce I like the idea of raunchy
sauce yeah but how do you approach like
coming to sex scenes now I'm sort of
like a sergeant major I'm very I
completely take control because
generally speaking I'm the only woman in
the room I'm very clear about what I'm
comfortable with what I'm not
comfortable with I have things in my
contract I have final say over the cut
and I'm very much like exactly what do
you want how is that shot working what
are we doing this you know I basically
take control of it but then I'm very
lucky because I'm in a position where I
can do that and I think really what
everyone's trying to do is protect those
actresses mainly who are in positions
where they can't do that and that's
where we've got to be protective as an
industry over young up-and-coming
actresses you know so but yeah I mean
the way that I deal with those things is
by being kind of as bullish as possible
the least sexy as possible and you know
we get through it but hey it looks sexy
on Catholics that same time it doesn't
matter right I was like oh I was like
she's going for it just go for it not my
body it was a body double oh yeah but
wonderful body it will bottom line but
like wonderful body a great what's so
amazing about that sex scene in
particular is its use is like a powerful
narrative for the women yes instead of
it being about the man so much because
it's like our liberation yeah you're
absolutely right yeah because how
liberating do you feel now because
obviously you've got everyone goes
through body journeys and relationships
their bodies as they go for their career
yeah how's your relationship with your
body changed throughout your career
would you say I'm at peace with my body
yeah you know it did something quite
amazing it built and carried and birth
fed a human being yeah an actual
real-life human being so I'm like it's
all fine it doesn't look like it did
before and maybe it will never be on
film again but I'm absolutely fine with
the way it is in my private life I'm
very happy that it did well yeah I think
that's such a good amazing message to
send out there to young girls and young
guys as well as to be like you know be
comfortable in your body is it serves
you so well that you draw it is a very
powerful tool don't wish it to be
something else it's never gonna be
something else it's gonna be what you've
got but it's gonna be all right yeah
look after it I was wondering what is
the most extreme aftermath you've
experienced after a big night now I mean
pretty extreme ones you know I'm in my
thirties now I had had a nice nice good
run of some pretty heavy hangovers yeah
what's your ultimate hangover cure it's
basically you just had to order lots of
Pizza I mean noodles I always like
noodles monitoring over but I mean and
and and just staying in bed which is now
impossible because I have a child and
there's no way she's gonna let me but
you know it so make the most of it now
that's like according to Keira Knightley
right that